[Music]
what's going on Shh
it's the trade deadline this could be
our ticket out of here
why would you want to leave aren't we in
line for the first pick no not because
that fool Billy King traded to Boston a
few years ago why I'm owed
they're coming they're coming I got back
up everybody back up
I'm sorry to announce we have made a
trade Oh YUM it's going to washing fell
sorry
oh my god they're like say what wins yes
34 wins
34 oh man there's like so many wins I
know you're disappointed but pack your
bags they expect you there on the morrow
right right oh yeah I'm very sad this is
source I'm very sad but I'll go pack now
and fight all the tears I love all you
guys thanks Lord Commander any other
trades to report or no okay now come on
it's time for practice tomorrow we lose
to the nun
[Music]
[Music]
the goes their house magic what are they
doing here
we don't plan for a full night what do
you want we want to propose a trade well
we don't need a trade
look intended oh come on now you're
fifth in the East you're worse than the
Hawks right now don't you want to
compete with the cab well right what do
you got
Serge Ibaka he shoots dunk and he's an
elite rim protector he's everything you
need
isn't that right Serge I defend anyone
he said LeBron all right okay well what
do you want for him DeMar DeRozan no
heat my friend oh very well worth a shot
then give us Norman Powell
no he's too young but we'll see your
friend Raj Norman trying to make a trade
hit
I am also with Fred all right well then
what else do you have to offer will give
you can we treat drink I don't think so
no what about Terrence what about Terry
you can have Terrence Ross well what
does he do he's like an older Norman no
not Tarrant you like in Orlando it's
warm
let the man speak Terrence what do you
do well I'm a pretty good 3d player
though some people might call me and
consisted so maybe I'm not a good three
declare and how you are I am a good
three indie player oh and a decorated
juggler not worried certainly
inconsistent throw in a draft pick and
it's a deal
a traffic fine but then you you got to
give us something else too something
else
all right we'll give you a choice you
can either have mario hezonia or this
horse well what is Mario do
he scores three points again and what
does the horse - it's a it's a horse it
walks around with people on it I don't
know
does horse things like it was a big pick
in the draft he's probably got potential
this horse will take the horse
[Music]
Oh